bonjour écoutez moi bien je suis retombé
dans une petite addiction que j'avais il
ya quelques temps une addiction au web
ou catcheur ces fameuses machines au
japon où il ya une pince tu mets un
héros et le but c'est d'essayer
d'attraper l'objet et c'est alors c'est
impossible de gagner en france ne éviter
d'y jouer parce que y'a vraiment 100
fois moins de chances de gagner que au
japon mais au japon il ya un vrai délire
challenge et tu peux vraiment réussir à
voir les objets quoi si tu travers donc
j'allais au japon là ya un mois vous
dans deux semaines et en fait j'ai pas
du tout fait du fo catcheur parce que
j'en ai beaucoup fait l'année dernière
et cette fois en fait j'avais une
nouvelle addiction c'était celle au
catch à pomme vous avez vu à quel point
j'en ai acheté beaucoup et à quelques
fois j'ai acheté beaucoup de gars
chapter chiba ce qui m'a mené bien
évidemment à cette magnifique collection
que tout le monde aimerait avoir chez
soi et à mon retour en fait je me suis
dit [ __ ] j'ai abusé des gars txapote
et j'ai fait zéro et focaccia rejeté dû
en faire un peu hélas jouvet mail par un
médecin de monnaie qui me dit le cas des
faits il ya deux ans une vidéo sur un
site ufo catcher il y avait de la
latence à mort et tous étaient hyper dur
il ya un nouveau site comme ça qui
marche d où cette fois ya zéro délai
c'est beaucoup plus simple de gagner et
s'est achevée sur ce site et mais qu'il
ya 1488 obligé différents 1404 oui je
sais pas la taille du building dans
laquelle il ya toutes ces machines les
mecs ça n'a aucun sens aujourd'hui nous
allons jouer edf aux catcheurs qu'en
effet ya deux ans sur un site un peu
moins foireux avec beaucoup plus de
l'eau j'ai fait des trucs qui
m'intéresse en plus c'est à la fin de la
vidéo je recevrai jeu les ouvriers enfin
j'espère si tout s'est bien passé si si
ça met un mois arrivait bien sorti à la
vidéo avant de recevoir mais je
partagerai s'assurer un statut et moi
excusez pas du tout faire basculer tu es
bon c'est pas une op je précise parce
qu'elle est enfin avec l'hebdo tik tok
les gens ont cru que snobé par tip top
non non c'est une opc spécifiant qu'une
communication commerciale vous
connaissez d'ailleurs vous vous sentez
vraiment pas obligé de jouer après a
revu la vidéo parce que c'est vraiment
extrêmement dure et ça coûte très cher
jean retrouver cette place sur un site
de revente et vous les aurez aux vrais
prix gauss qui écoule ce site là c'est
que on peut voir les gens en train de
jouer et viennent sur deux files
d'attentes juste eu un objet mais qui a
déjà des gens qui sont en train
d'essayer de la voir si tu peux la file
d'attenté t'attendais tu le vois jouer
et ce qu'il y'a que moi je trouve ça
génial will là par exemple il ya quatre
mecs en attente et ont des 37 à le
regarder je vous rendez compte ou pas il
ya toujours deux caméras une de côté une
devant comme d'habitude le but c'est de
faire tomber le lot si tu le fais tomber
it it l'endroit bon bref j'ai repéré un
item qui me plaît énormément je sais pas
pourquoi il m'attire mais il m'attire je
saurais pas expliquer cette belle caméra
depuis la vidéo sur les rings dans
réglages un délire et que gameiro mais
que je ne viens pas annoncer je veux
refaire cet objet jeu
mais très là dans mon décor ça n'aura
pas du tout sa place à voix très moche
c'est vraiment les objets où tu sens
vraiment le made in china et quand tu
vois dans les magasins tu les achètent
pas du tout quand il apparaît sur ce
site dans un ufo et où ils ont l'air
giniaux alors je sais qu'ils sont nuls à
chier ok c'est parti y'a que moi y'a
personne sur la machine y'a que moi moi
et moi seul
on met un crédit on appuie sur le bouton
alors maintenant d'un coup on va y aller
c'est parti voyez une latorse il ya une
latence de bahts un mec je vais
réellement galets oh là là ça va
peut-être ça me blessait
elle passe limites oui et non elle est
bien les biens et alors je pensais
qu'ils connaissent pas le de vous dire
mais le quai elle a bougé d'un
centimètre ad'autant famer de faire tout
et youtube heures vers les 3 mois de
pâques mais je vous assure que c'était
un beau move
le but ça va être qu'elle tombe comme ça
et ensuite de la levée pour qu'elle
bascule incompréhensible journée allez
on y va on donne tout ce qu'on a en
stock
ok parfait ah non je suis pile sur la
marche on attendait en fait il ya du
délai ne croyez pas que c'est que je
suis au nul à tokoin que non ça va ça
l'obligé à trembler en fait c'est pas de
chez nul c'est qu'il ya un vrai délai du
coup bah je suis ça me rend nul donc en
fait il sait que je suis nul on a déjà
nyc & cie crédit c'est bon pour vous ok
ok bien on regarde moi je l'aurais
jamais j'ai perdu espoir
ça ne bouge pas d'un pet fait je lui dis
la vérité en fait je sais comment ça
marche je vous dis en anecdotes sais pas
si je l'avais dit dans la presse vidéo
fo catcheur mais en gros en fait la
pince c'est pas genre à elles ont toutes
la même puissance et c'est pas du tout
ces genres ya un mec qui vient et qui
touche au bouton de la machine et qui
change la force verticales horizontales
et c'est donc là je suis quasi sûr
qu'après que le gars est gagné le mec la
machine est venu et à baisser la
puissance de la pince pour pas que simon
gagne 20 mai regard ils tremblent à
peine mec je vais essayer d'aller franco
au milieu
[Musique]
mais je vous dis la vérité
est-ce que chez vous vous avez fait au
parce que en gros là je peux plus le
gagner en voilà c'est impossible que je
gagne donc gesca pas un bouton pour dire
aux gars genre genre de le bouger quoi
j'ai trois vieillards mais il y en a un
qui en réserve
il ya un mec qui a réservé sa place ce
bâtard je vous mets des crédits jamais
tu me do make say ma caméra mais jamais
je te laisse jouer
si la réserve et s'il ya moyen de la
voir cet objet donc je vais tout donner
pour l'avoir même si je sais pas trop
comment faire commencer comme ça pas mal
pas mal pas mal si je me prends pas la
barre on est bien yes j'ai ce prix là
bas ça monsieur qui est pas un bouton
pour appeler le gars pour qui le replace
si vous allez au japon la technique
c'est vous appelez le 1 mec de la salle
pour qu'il vous leur place je connais ce
game les gars là je connais tu aurais
bas est en train de marquer et il ya des
millions de rands chanson born 720 de
m'arnaquer ferions mieux de m'envoyer
directement cette caméra ça me ferait
très plaisir
voilà c'est pas mal là juste avant la
barre genre attention peut être pas mal
oui c'est pas des fois il faut savoir se
dire que ça passera jamais il faut faire
passer à autre chose mais c'est dur on
est dans un moment douloureux tous
ensemble mais on le vit tous ensemble on
va se ressaisir tous ensemble pour avoir
un objet vous en faites pas alors qu'est
ce cas qu'est-ce qui a d'autre
d'intéressant attend un aspirateur
automatique seraient bien utiles après
un passage mcfly karine torchi pas ou
que je suis attiré par ce à quoi les
genres vraiment mille trucs géniaux je
suis attiré par les toucs électronique
pour is incroyable au québec
oh [ __ ] y en train de jouer quatre
cadres ont réservé tout le monde
l'aspirateur merde personnes hadas purge
pour vous qu'est ce qui se passe là ok
je suis sur une tirelire ou quand tu
mets une pièce de dans le gun s'allume
au bout je vous jure
mais c'est quoi cette machine vendue
comme en basque vous faire c'est un
élastique c'est quoi je vais jamais vu
çà de là au japon vas-y et donc white
shadow même si je gagne pas je m'en fous
c'est plat satisfaisant mais maigre
comme je sais citons pas quand je suis
bon comme ça il tombera jamais mec c'est
impossible tu te prends un coup comme ça
de la pince mexes est transverse déjà
des bases dans la brume wahaha tanger
méga bonne stratégie
vous êtes prêts
ok c'est bon on l'a
car et c'est horrible mais que j'appuie
dessus il à la verticale il tombe pas
non mais que possible mais aucun objet
ou humain s'est fait secouer comme ça de
sa vie je suis désolé il veut quand même
pas tomber c'est incroyable mais je
viens de mettre 60 balles s'te plaît
fais le tombé je mens vous êtes vous en
train de montrer à des millions de gens
que c'est de la pure avec moi qui ai
défendu les juifs aux captures du japon
il ya deux minutes au pelage gris
alors je sais pas c'est quoi la marque
du [ __ ] d'élastiques qui retient
l'objet mais il manque clairement je
vais en acheter c'est ça que je veux
gagner maintenant c'est même plus
l'objet c'est l'élastique quoi il est
incroyable c'est lastic attend dé voir
en vrai je vais laisser ma place aux
autres et on va voir s'il y arrive si
j'y arrive genre en trois coups mec
alors que je viens de mettre 80 balle
dedans j'ai un seul à déjouer toi qui es
plus mal
montrez nous comment tu fais la halle à
la voile a fait le malin aussi génial
quand tu viens de perdre 60 balais que
tu regardes un mec qui va perdre 60
balles aussi on va avoir un objet n'y a
pas du tout et les cours dès janvier
dans tout télécommandé ya bientôt
télécommande et attends je trouve un
tout et les commandes et moi ou robots
de karrada a les shorts on va voir
[Musique]
olala attend tout autant je me lève de
son siège il bouge beaucoup mais il faut
matin si j'avais mais tous les essais
que j'ai mis dans l'eau dans celui-là
mais quand j'en serais pas là je suis un
[ __ ] débine mais je veux décrocher
leur billet une vidéo sympa que de
montage on en est là aujourd'hui
franchement ça agrippant franchement
avec beaucoup d'essais et de patience
mec c'est la méga douilles
ça commence à m'énerver là l édredon la
gamme et à skis leur place et où est ce
qu'il l'a replacé ni vu ni connu grâce à
l'amour fou mais qu il
il l'a remis mais qu elle est exactement
comme elles étaient tout à l'heure mais
quand je vous dis exactement ces gens
exactement mais vous savez quoi cette
[ __ ] de caméras je vais la voir mon
pote
[Musique]
assez soigné s'il est pressé pas sur la
barre
[Musique]
2-0 qui veut nicaise unique si ça
bascule comme thaler c'est mort allez
hop on quitte cette merde t'as grosse
attend il ya un mec qui m'a volé jack ma
place pour la caméra sillage il l'aura
jamais quoi que mais qu en ont il va la
voir
oh non je veux ma place au nom makes him
la vole c'est un désastre
oh non il va la voir s'ils l'avalent max
est le fils de deux mois mais son
trombone mec la honte c'est comme si on
venait de me voler comme ça il me vient
de passer la même chose au web
allez je tente la deuxième machine à les
voilà on commence tout de suite par une
barre mais c'est pas grave le joueur
français il ya quatre mecs en réserve
c'est mort celle là elle est à moi qu'on
le déplace plus adaptées à chaque cas
vous vous dites mais mec c'est nul je
vous jure contre des places petit à
petit
c'est moi jamais je leur ai exigé qu
site sa poésie mais je suis découragée
là par contre je vous dis un truc si le
mec là il chaud ils reçoivent la caméra
alors que moi je les paye je vais dingue
parce que quelqu'un eut le déraillement
le truc avec l'élastique là c'est
tellement là d'où il se règle à vitteaux
mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya un truc juste je
peux gagner même si c'est nul
même si genre grave de la merde car
jusque symboliquement contre mes deux
ans balle j'ai eu un truc c'est quoi ça
une toupie une petite toupie c'est pas
dur à gagner une toupie genre mais il a
tout pigé tendant de la toupie basij
transat ou pis on va avoir un objet
allez stop les jeux les premiers coups
je lai je vois un truc tomber dans le
trou n'importe quoi tomber dans le trou
se blesse allez on y retourne la toupie
aller pour lui qui est ce qu'on va se
marrer c'est quand même une sacrée
toupie quoi allez on y va on est un peu
décalé mais c'est pas grave regardez
c'est manon oui j'en ai marre de me
prendre la douille
ça commence à bien faire donner moi
c'est tout
allez je tente une dernière fois
histoire de bien amusé et d'avoir du
contenu pour ma vidéo mais j'ai
clairement même plus envie d'avoir cette
toupie elle ne mérite pas oh que non je
suis allé trop loin c'est est ce que
c'est la barre peut-être une barre oui
ma ba une massue en train de devenir bon
trouvons un objet qui nous plaît et
donnons tout ce qu'on a pour l'avoir
tout allez on va y arriver on finira pas
cette vidéo sur avoir gagné un objet je
vous le dis en fait j'ai compris c'est
ce qu'ils font les gens qui vont sur le
site ils regardent les objets là où il
ya marqué sa corne kings baiano
employeurs où il ya déjà un mec en train
de jouer et ils attendent qu'ils bougent
le truc à fond et qui quitte en pensant
qu'il a aucune chance de gagner pour ce
faire le mouv qu'il fallait pour faire
tomber l'objet pour genre seulement 5
euros alors que le tabac il à 1070 et
moi j'ai été vraiment ce gala trop con
qui n'ont mec non attends il ya un autre
mais qui va gagner la caméra devant nous
et nos yeux là ça serait tellement moi
je me mens nathan de direct elle est là
sa place laisse moi ta place graux
t'inquiète je vais laver à tout mais je
te l'envoie pro b oui il a abandonné
j'aurai cette caméra je l'installerai et
helm évitera un cambriolage vous allez
voir malabar [ __ ] mais pas la barre
j'avais cru aussi c'est la bonne c'est
la bonne je crois
[ __ ] mais qui me reste que 9500 crédit
on a quatre essais c'est fini on y va
non je vais romain demi non non non
[Musique]
mais que c'est la bonne les astres sont
alignés le monde entier regarde musi
mattila voir sa caméra
[Musique]
j'arrive pas à tous je suis désolé je ne
me faire démolir mais morts je ne veux
prendre la douille de ma vie lâche il ya
double de malades
écoutez moi bien je suis extrêmement
heureux d'avoir gagné cette erreur je
vais payer cher mais au moins je les
juge aurait pu ne rien à voir au bon et
ça c'est horrible on la gelée eu certes
à un prix trois fois supérieur à celui
que j'aurais payé si je m'étais fait
arnaquer par du drop shipping
mais au moins je les ai eus à la sueur
de mon front aussi je sais nous rassurer
j'ai hâte que reçoivent la caméra et
gégé aucun doute sur le fait qu'elle
sera grave qui animait après tout c'est
pas pour rien qu'on a autant galéré à la
voir avec elle nous revient si cher
c'est pas pour rien
je vous fuit du regarde j'ai honte
nous sommes dix jours après ce que vous
venez voir et je n'ai toujours pas reçu
la caméra j'ai reçu seulement hier un
lien par mail pour suivre mon colis et
apparemment il arrive demain à roissy
charles de gaulle qui veut dire qu'il
arrive chez moi dans trois ou quatre
jours donc je me suis non seulement fait
arnaquer j'ai payé une caméra
probablement factices ah oui j'ai
réalisé que vu la gueule du packaging et
où en fait c'est sûrement une fausse
caméra c'est sûr et certain mais au
moins j'ai joué j'étais convaincu que
c'était une vraie peut-être parce que
bah quand tu mets plus de 200 euros dans
un truc tu dis bon bah c'est forcément
un vrai mais non c'est un jeu de hasard
et de chance le prix de revient du
produit n'est pas forcément révélateur
de la qualité de celui-ci mais mec c'est
frustrant non seulement je me fais
douillet mais en plus j'ai même pas le
colis pour la fin de la vidéo [ __ ] du
coup d'éclat reçoit déjà des ballerines
en story ou quoi je filmerai ici et je
là je mettrai ça sur un stade pour vous
voyez quand même le 7 c'est incroyable
caméra
j'espère quand même la vidéo vous aura
plu moi même si je me suis fait arnaquer
ça m'a plu je ne le ferai jamais de la
vie tout seul dans mon coin mais avec
vous je dois admettre c'était un bon
moment
c'était bien marrant j'espère vous avez
aussi passer un bon moment désolé pour
cette fois un peu frustrante mais vous
n'en faites pas pour la frustration dans
quelques jours sur un stade quand je
déballais la caméra cachée l'objet en
plastique sur une caméra [ __ ]
attention quand même se désamorce nous
éviter ce genre de jeux qui sont
vraiment basé sur la chance et vous avez
finalement beaucoup pas perdre je veux
dire je suis sur cette caméra elle est
dispo sur des sites de revente chinois
là pour 5,3 euros même et pas deux
sortes du tout me sens obligé de
désamorcer parce que moi je le prends
avec le sourire c'est dans le but de
vous divertir et qu'on s'amuse que je l'
ai fait mes jouets pas ce genre de truc
seuls dans votre coin c'est sauf si
vraiment vous avez de l'argent à perdre
sur ce je vous dis à bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo avec peut-être une
j'arriverai le canard j'arrête c'est bon
je fais un blocage je vous dis à bientôt
tout court portez vous bien merci
d'avoir regardé hasta la vista ciao
[Musique]